[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat poursuivre le travail
du sénat pendant cette crise du
coronavirus on va parler aujourd'hui
d'europe puisque les sénateurs ont
auditionné le commissaire européen au
marché intérieur thierry breton est une
question se pose que font les pays de
l'union européenne pour sauver les
entreprises pendant cette crise on sait
que la commission européenne doit
présenter dans les prochaines semaines
un plan de relance qui pourrait
atteindre 1500 milliards d'euros
c'est-à-dire 10% de la richesse
européenne produite en une année tout de
suite l'audition de thierry breton cité
le commissaire merci merci beaucoup
d'avoir accepté aujourd'hui nous avons
réduit notre présence d'officiels
annexes qui participe pas à ces pays
membres puissent être pudiquement moules
ou de leur poule 1 la surenchère
ce prêt le jour les listes qui sont
également présents à cette mesure est le
bon fonctionnement des marchés et donner
un élan à la finalisation
primo nous a directement entamé ces deux
fronts d'une part les continents s'est
imposé comme la solution efficace il
faut ça monde il à remettre en cause les
libertés vous a plus ou moins chez ea
régulier des frontières en fumant cook
et donc le coeur de la construction
d'hôtels qui touchait mais évidemment
ont des qualités de leur interconnexion
dû organiser les flux indispensable au
maintien des chaînes
de rapatriement de chaque euro dans son
pays la qualité réelle et maintenance
industrielle dans lequel se trouvera
d'abord en matière de médicaments
continuent à seulement sont évoluer les
esprits ont également d'ici là les
larmes aux visions politiques
européennes de concurrence est un sujet
sur lequel sénat s'est penché déjà pas
mal les nouveaux canons révolution la
réflexion a bien pensé que la nouvelle
chance il faut que nous allions bien
politiques que globalement le concept
d'autonomie stratégique et vendus par la
france qui lui confère selon lui qu'un
film à thématique sociale se disait
logiquement c'est moi j'ai manqué c'est
bien quand ils attestent rapide
kevin d'autre part l'activité européenne
une vente par les européens a basculé en
télétravail vivement au mépris parfois
de nous une chance comme iris
il est des questions en outre les deux
gérants gala présenté un gars pour la
levée document qui commence à se
dessiner
elle conditionne la demande de
cautionnement possibilité de la
condamnée a suivi la même d'une
surveillance de
numérique comment garantie contribution
qu'ils n'enquêtent pas excessivement sur
les libertés
il y aura un débat par moments la fin du
mois sur ce sujet et personnellement
j'ai comme la trempe les deux amis des
relents porte sur la grèce mais c'est la
vie comment éviter que quand on perd ça
n'en soit pas achevée nous avons noté
quelques unes des romans qu'ils ne
contaminent en raison de ses fêtes les
soirs des larmes et à l'onu elle en
train de s'essouffler de vous poser je
peux faire je vous invite à répondre à
cette première question une endroit le
tout chanté sénateurs merci merci
beaucoup je peux dire merci merci à vous
toutes et vous tous d'être peut-être
connecter avec nous avec nous
aujourd'hui c'est désormais un nouveau
moyen de nous exprimer que de travailler
l'un de ses milieux conférence soit que
tout le monde a bien appris à le faire
fonctionner j'entends que tout le monde
est bien sûr mi août c'est extrêmement
important pour que la qualité il faut
toujours vérifier du reste dans ce type
d'exercice qu'on est tous bien sûr le
mieux de façon à ce que chacun puisse
bien s'entendre mais je vois que au
sénat monsieur présent des disciplines
et j'ai l'impression que tout le monde à
part peut-être un ou deux mais qui vont
corriger tout de suite ils sont bien
payés être sûr mi août de façon à ce
qu'on puisse vraiment avoir un échange
nous des choses de qualité d'abord de
vous remercier d'avoir convié à 70 cette
audition dans le cadre de deux
commissions la commission des affaires
européennes la commission des affaires
économiques
pour faire un petit point évidemment on
va le qualifié d' accord de point
d'étape
parce que on est évidemment encore dans
la lutte contre la pandémie
il faut évidemment jamais l'oublier même
si évidemment on doit on doit penser
aussi certains qualifient ça qu'elle est
fine monde après c'est-à-dire pas
simplement là à la fin 2-2 puis se
devait de donner la galerie il vient ce
serait avec vitrine avec grand plaisir
que je sais je sais je sais je sais
qu'elle est chez elle et je crois que
dans un département qui n'est pas très
éloigné d'ici voilà est-ce que je peux
répéter ce que vous disiez la présidence
oui je vous écoute mais il faut nous
donner la parole à vous développiez mon
micro
alors notre micro blogging en torno
ce que vous m'entendez vous m'entendez
oui c'est bon les yvelines ne sont pas
très loin de paris en effet monsieur le
commissaire mais quelquefois les
mystères de la technique mes chers
collègues merci monsieur le président
visait de me donner quelques instants la
parole monsieur le commissaire je veux
dire que nous nous réjouissions de votre
arrivée à la commission mais pendant
cette période nous au régime y sont deux
fois plus plus jamais que plus que
jamais cette crise met évidemment en
évidence le besoin de coordination
européenne n'ont sûrement non seulement
pour parer à l'urgence économique que
nous traversons mais aussi pour préparer
la prêt pour préparer cette fameuse
relance qu'une deuxième étape est une
troisième étape qui sont les chantiers
futurs à m'entendais pas si c'est bon là
très bon voilà je crois qu'il ya des
personnes qui ont des micros ouverts
elle avait peut-être ça fait un peu de
un peu de troupes
alors bien sûr la réponse à la crise
c'est bien sûr le mécanisme européen de
stabilité de 240 milliards c'est aux
siens un fonds de relance et c'est
probablement en particulier en tant que
président de la commission des affaires
économiques se font de relance que je
voudrais évidemment plus tôt vous
entendre on s'assure un petit peu quels
sont les axes sur lesquels vous
travaillez comment vous allez faire le
choix des sujets sur lesquels vous allez
orienter ses fonds et bien sûr on ne
peut plus parler aujourd'hui de monde
d'après sans parler d'une forme de
résilience qui nous est apparue
défaillante de la part de l'ensemble de
notre pays et probablement de
souveraineté ce qui n'est pas du
souverainisme qui venaient vite pas à la
fermeture de notre continent
or est au reste du monde bien sûr en
matière industrielle nous sommes très
intéressés par le cas des champions
européens tout à l'heure on parlera
probablement avec alain chatillon du
rapport qui sont commises sur alstom
siemens avec martial bourquin et puis
lors de votre audition par la commission
denquête au sénat et j'en dise elle a
dit vous avez parlé de souveraineté
numérique avec mon collègue franck
montaugé qui vous interrogera bien sûr
nous sommes intéressés pour savoir
comment rapidement maintenant nous
allons pouvoir avancer sur cette partie
du numérique
par ailleurs vous avez récemment appelez
de vos voeux la création d'un fonds de
reconversion industrielle européen
peut-être pouvez-vous nous détailler
quels en seraient les missions les
moyens comment tout cela va s'articuler
comment s'assurer que l'on mise sur les
secteurs d'avenir les plus innovants
mais sans oublier non plus l'industrie
traditionnelle qui a besoin d'être
également soutenu enfin sur le numérique
président disait vous a évidemment poser
les questions qu'il fallait je ne vais
pas insister
peut-être vous pourrez également vous
rappeler les actions de l'union
européenne afin de coordonner autant que
possible la proche des pays membres
quant à l'utilisation des technologies
numériques
maintenant pour lutter contre le coc vie
de 19 évidemment le traçage était un
sujet jean bizet l'a dit mais vous
pourrez peut-être nous dire ce que vous
pensez des initiatives d'apple et de
google et l'initiative d'orange maman
qui ne vous est pas tout à fait
étrangère voilà merci monsieur
commissaire et pardon pour ses problèmes
de connexion
j'invite mon micro merci merci madame la
présidente maintenant vous êtes trop
bien très bien entendu et j'ai bien noté
tout eu toutes vos toutes vos questions
qui sont évidemment très très des
victimes en cette période très
singulière que nous vivons tous ces
corps dit tout c'est bien entendu nous
tous français nous tous européens mais
mais mais quelque part me tous humains
sur sur la planète
peut-être bénéfique tous les micros sont
bien couper les questions ce qui est pas
d'écho comme
ce qu'on m'entend ah c'est bon c'est bon
donc
donc je rappeler quand on est encore
évidemment dans le temps ce combat
contre contre contre 6 pour l'acompte
contre le virus
donc tous nos compatriotes peu con
citoyens européens mais aussi et peut
dire d'une façon ou d'une autre tout cas
canettes qui se bat contre contre ce
virus et 40 la situation
particulièrement singulière et inédite
alors pour répondre aux différentes
interrogations vous avez formulées l'une
et l'autre
même la présence monsieur le président
je dois d'être rappelé que les choses
soient claires mais il faut toujours
dire personne aucun pays n'était préparé
à une tel produit
je dis bien aucun nous l'avons vécu nous
évidemment la commission de façon très
claire je rappelle que lorsque la crise
a apparu en chine à la fin de l'année
dernière machine et action va pas prêtes
à subir ce choc et nous appeler au
secours notamment la commission et
l'union européenne pour faire face
évidemment armes
cette situation inédite à laquelle elle
était confrontée et nous allons nous
demander des masques elle me demandait
des gants évidement d'été les lunettes
de mode et des ventilateurs sur le
respirateur artificiel
nous avons immédiatement immobilisé 56
tonnes de matériel on a oublié d'ajouter
puisque le montant très significatif
d'argent pour aider la chine dans cette
situation où elle était doublement pas
préparés pour faire face à la
spontanéité et d'ampleur de la crise je
rappelle parce que ce qu'on vit
évidemment cette situation un peu
différée nous avons fait ce que nous
devions faire et on aller par la
commission on a tout de suite
et prenez présent à l'appel du peuple
chinois et de la demande et du reste
certaine discrétion et c'est tout à fait
normal qu on obtempère à leurs souhaits
et donc on l'a fait sans être trop trop
trop haut visible sauf la soirée d'hier
s'était joué et nous les avons
évidemment suivi ce qui était important
c'était l'action humanitaire que nous
demandait quelques mois plus tard
évidemment la pandémie s'est passé en
europe
ce qui est important c'est qu'entre
temps la chine a monté très haut très
très rapidement ses cadences notamment
voir matériel du nom de protection des
personnels de santé 1
ces fameux ppe dont on parle évidemment
maintenant à juste titre très très très
souvent et c'est tout à fait normal les
masques les basques radicaux les masques
les deux situés matin de protection des
personnels de santé et puis évidemment
des patients de la sur eux-mêmes et
bientôt aussi de nous tous notamment
dans la phase de déconfinement dans
laquelle ils espèrent tous et bientôt
bientôt entrer entre temps la chine a
monté ses capacités de production
d'équipements en quelques mois le
produit aujourd'hui à peu près 150
millions de masques par jour donc à kuyt
qui va dans exporter donc dès que
endémie a commencé à prendre de
l'ampleur
d'abord en italie évidemment on a tout
de suite avant même que la commission de
préciser par les états membres
mission de supervision des matériels de
protection rappelle que la santé était
la responsabilité exclusive des états
mans et ça me semble parfaitement
légitime je pense qu'il faut que ça le
demeure
mais face évidemment besoins urgents
comme la chine avait vécu en son temps
de ces équipements
quelques semaines après la mer' jans de
lame d'au delà de l'épidémie depuis la
pandémie en italie évidemment demandé à
la commission donc bien ses missions de
mission de supervision et de contrôle on
veut dire de l'ensemble des équipements
nécessaires et d'approvisionnement et
dont j'ai eu la responsabilité en tant
que commissaire au marché intérieur
mais j'avais pas attendu du respect je
me la confier pour appeler immédiatement
déjà l'ensemble des fabricants de ces
équipements en europe avait une dizaine
je me dis ça parce que vous allez voir
les chiffres énormément évolué ce qui
montre leur activité aussi de nos
entreprises européennes françaises mais
aussi européennes en la matière elle
s'est formidablement réagi depuis à part
deux ou par trois la production en
quelques semaines
et puis et puis surtout j'ai appelé en
les réunissant l'ensemble des industries
du textile commence à convertir sa tenue
de production je voudrais porter
témoignage ici de leur formidable
réactivité sont tous mobilisés dont les
familles les plus grandes chaînes ne pas
hésitez pas faire de publicité mais
enfin même s'il le mérite et je veux
surtout pas en oublier qu'ils ont été
très nombreux si je vous dis ça c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya 500 d'entreprise
500 qui fournissent aujourd'hui des
masques en europe
y'a pas à moi il avait dit oui
la montée la montée s'est fait très
rapidement
évidemment j'espère que à terme on sera
autosuffisant dans ce type de matériel
de protection
bien sûr il faut moi qui paie tout le
monde et notamment dans la phase 2 de
déconfinement mais voilà partis sans
doute nécessité d'avoir une autonomie
dans ce type d'équipement
puisque on l'a vu c'est un élément qui
est absolument indispensable
voilà je voulais porter ce témoignage
pour vous dire qu'il ya une réaction
extraordinairement rapide positive est
sûr en tout temps on ne sait pas assez
de bataille et knock on a continué à en
importer pas que de chine y reste
on l'a trouvé mais j'espère que un
horizon assez rapide en soit tout
suffisant nouveau plaint de ce type
d'équipement c'était le problème c'est
le cas aussi des ventilateurs des
respirateurs artificiels et là aussi de
mobilisation formidable un ennemi
ensemble des les acteurs et mais aussi
ceux qui était consultant automobile les
constructeurs aéronautiques autour par
exemple d'air liquide que vous savez
peut-être d'un consortium s'est créé
avec
des constructeurs automobiles des
constructeurs aéronautiques qui en est
ces consortiums en liquide fournit c'est
je crois un peu près entre 500 et 1000
respirateur par an pendant les 50 jours
qui viennent ça fait commencé il ya
trois quatre semaines donc il reste
encore un petit mois ils vont fournir 10
milliards voyez quoi il y avait quand
même une très forte et très peu de
réactivité alors si je vous dis ça c'est
pour répondre à votre question monsieur
le président comme il dit c'est
effectivement au début de vie active
mans une réaction ou le sentiment que
les marchés se fermer il ya eu vraiment
une réaction de personnes s'attendaient
à une telle rapidité côte est du reste
un bon pas dû les informations
nécessaires qui aurait permis peut-être
à l'europe de mieux se préparer
en tout cas c'est vrai qu'on a vu tout
de suite certains pays dont l'allemagne
qui a fermé ses frontières aux et
quelques problèmes j'ai dû beaucoup
batailler avec avec mes amis et les
ministres de l'économie de la santé pour
qui la parole rapidement la france avait
une façon aussi réduit la passage de ses
frontières alors sur un autre critère
était le critère on avait vu que
notamment en france outre nos droits
notre papy du rock à faire un certain
nombre de spéculations voire de trafic
pouvait s'opérer ce type de matériel dès
l'origine de la crise voulue à prendre
le temps de bien regarder ce qui se
passe et de dévaluer la disponibilité
sur le territoire national et donc de
mettre en ordre
tout ça bon assez rapidement les
frontières de son lever d'autres pays
les enfermer je vous dirais tu fais tu
vas y assez assez quotidien la parc
vous veillez à ce que parce que dès
qu'un pays réagisse de cette façon et
bien il n'a vu ses frontières le plus
rapidement possible donc j'ai dit la
bulgarie la tchéquie les ont enlevés
l'allemagne l'a entièrement le vestiaire
c'était très important
la slovaquie la roumanie partiellement
la france l'italie de la pologne est
encore quelques aux inspections qui
persistent pour la bulgarie la hongrie
la l'été
la lettonie et la slovaquie mais je
pense que tout ça va promettre
normalement être réduits et je rappelle
que lors du dernier conseil du 26 mars
on avait été évoquée il ya un conseil
européen qui sert comme vous savez ce
que dit donc je pense que là tout sera à
peu près régulièrement tout cas j j
veille dans le cadre de mes
responsabilités et je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui est qui et qui
maintenant est derrière nous ça a été
vrai aussi pour certains médicaments
donc là encore on a eu on a eu ces
réactions qui était direction essaye on
n'avait pas vu que en europe parce que
quand la pandémie a traversé
l'atlantique et a commencé à frapper
durement maintenant est très dur a moins
comme on le sait le territoire
nord-américain on avait aussi des
réactions tout à fait extraordinaire au
prétendu terme est doté d'une île des
états américains se sont fermées fermez
les fronts leurs frontières carrément la
garde nationale qui empêchait des
traversées par exemple mais pendant un
moment la frontière entre le cas de new
york et du new jersey qui était fermée
où les identique avec un cône étiquette
enfin j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie
donc voilà donc on a eu il ya eu des
réactions et une réaction là aussi et
qui ont été un peu spontané et donc je
crois qu'il faut les prendre pour ce
qu'elles sont notamment pas toujours se
dire ah bah c'est l'europe qui voit là
ça a été des réactions je dirais humaine
y compris de responsables politiques
sont en exercice et qui reviennent
évidemment la responsabilité première
qui au tgcc ses compatriotes ou pour les
gouverneurs des états ceux qui sont
membres de les deux états ce
comportement est un comportement je
dirais humain et pas européen je le dis
parce que le rap foule dense est dans
cette affaire c'est je trouve très
sincèrement très bien comporté et être
rapidement et nous avons là encore en
respectant vous savez à chaque fois que
je parlais un ministre qui avait fermé
ses frontières
j'ai commencé si tu mens pas de dire que
je comprends jeu pour parce que je le
comprends je comprends ce que vous vivez
je comprends votre action est maintenant
là comment refaire et comment on peut
faire procéder et en trouver la solution
et est finalement les atouts
il ya eu encore quelques problèmes
évidents passage aux frontières
le camion des là on a mis en place des
green light et et greenland des
corridors spécifiés spéciaux pour
pouvoir le faire passer j'ai utilisé les
services aussi un de copernicus qui nous
donnait dans steam
on avait bien identifié l'ensemble des
frontières ou des quelques points de
passage en fait j'avais une carte c'est
toujours quotidienne on peut ensemble
des laits des points un peu critique
pour voir s'il ya s'il ya des on voit
tout de suite les files de camions et
des files de camions intervient
directement mais je crois pouvoir vous
dire aujourd'hui que ces problèmes sont
fond derrière nous et quelle mise à part
les premières réactions tranchées un peu
comment dirais-je compréhensible on
étire les choses sont revenus dans un
dom dans une normalité notamment pour le
fonctionnement du marché intérieur qui
est absolument essentiel et le transport
des matériels et des matières premières
et les coûts des matières critique
évidemment dont les matières de 2
centimes un autre point que vous avez
évoquées qui était de make your eyes
juste corrigé peut-être une toute petite
vous avez appelé monsieur le président
il ne s'agit pas d'utiliser les
technologies pour mieux surveiller nos
concitoyens jamais l'union européenne a
été extrêmement stricte sur ce point
j'aimais et je le dis d'autant mieux que
je veux m'en suis occupé moi même et
c'est donc on se connaît un peu c'est
vrai que c'est pas dans ma philosophie
est donc j'ai été extrêmement précis et
sur ce qu'on pouvait faire
et ce qui me semblait être peut-être
plus sujets à caution
d'abord sur ce qu'on pouvait faire on
est vraiment dans une situation
extraordinaire reconnaissance du terme
et donc la première ma première réaction
lorsque on a confiné progressivement
tous les pays et puis et puis quasiment
la moitié de la planète 1 4 milliard
d'habitants confinés
ah ça a été de me demander si le réseau
internet elle est allé tenir parce que
l'ancien président france télécom que je
suis ouais c'est que les réseaux sont
dimensionnés pour certaines choses mais
enfin quand même des limites en tout cas
il on n'a jamais conçu des réseaux ou
une situation de cette nature
d'autant que les usages évoluent et que
non quand on est confiné à domicile on a
utilisé ses réseaux pour télétravailler
d'utiliser notamment les systèmes vidéo
comme ceux que nous utilisons à
l'instant pour apprendre ça c'est quand
même très nouveau dopée par ce type de
technologie ça consomme d'accord
passante mais aussi pour se distraire on
connaît déjà
bon c'est pour quand est ce que des
fournisseurs de contenu pour ne citer
que ceux là ma faim comme on le sait
comme à nantes netflix youtube dans
certains pays consomme près de la moitié
de l'apprendre passante 2-2 fournisseurs
de contenus et donc jouer ce communiqué
continue à avoir une activité et des
liens sociaux et les plateformes donc
donc j'ai pu continuer d'appeler
directement mal des principaux
fournisseurs jeu direct de prestataires
utilise d'habitude nos réseaux et nos
réseaux européens pour leur demander de
réduire la bande passante qui l'utilisé
et notamment en réduisant peut-être pour
notamment ceux qui fournissent et des
contenus vidéo et des séries et autres
qui réduisent la qualité sans que ce
soit pour autant nuisible aux
téléspectateurs ou aux spectateurs à et
de façon à les libérer pour les autres
activités que tout ça finalement
fonctionne bien et je veux dire que là
encore une très bonne réactivité une
très bonne réaction 24 heures ils ont
baissé à maintenant voilà on appelle
john légiférer ou non n'a pas eu besoin
de prendre des mesures contraignantes
on a on a on a discuté et est tombé
c'est de libérer 25 ans en bande
passante chacun donc ça nous a permis de
bien et d'avoir je met pas du tout en
cause a quitté nos réseaux télécoms je
les connais 60 parmi les plus robustes
au monde pur muscle notamment
beaucoup de soja connaissent d'autres
continents dont huit parmi ceux qui sont
les plus développés donc mais c'est une
situation inédite qui valait mieux
prévenir que d'avoir intervenir derrière
puis on structure aurès si je dois
fonctionné et n'ont absolument
voilà pour faire ça donc ça c'est le
premier aspect le deuxième aspect c'est
qu'évidemment prépare-t-il moment où la
commission s'est vu confier une mission
de supervision des précédents qu'une
fois de le faire à un point entre le
l'état des stocks des matériels de santé
la demande veiller à ce que les
approvisionnements arrivent notamment
que les commandes puis 7 passes et c'est
donc à un essai de vision générale puis
faire en sorte évidemment que ces
équipements arrivent en priorité là où
les pic de la pandémie arrive est
stockée par précaution il fallait
vraiment j'aurais la situation je dirais
en temps réel y compris sur le continent
européen
là on en a envie et je rappelle qu'on a
envoyé un million de battre en italie et
l allemagne a également c'était un peu
de temps après le début de cette montée
en flèche du pic terrible que tu as
connu dans la région du nord de l'italie
à vidy dit on sait on sait on s'est
rendu compte qu'il nous fallait des
outils pour essayer d'anticiper un peu
l'évolution des pics alors existe des
modèles évidemment des modèles
mathématiques des modèles sont sur
fondée sur l'expérience qu'on a pu
acquérir des dernières dernière pandémie
donc c'est faux que ces modèles on les
avait fonctionné évidemment on avait il
y en avait une dimension nouvelle qui
étaient les dimensions de fait que 80%
de la population ont été confinés donc
là ça changeait complètement la nature
même des modèles mathématiques pour
pouvoir prévoir dimanche
l'évolution de la pandémie l'arrivée du
pic et qui 70 restants plateau et puis
ensuite qui décroît et donc essayer de
voir quel serait le pays et travailler
ensuite des lieux géographiques où vous
devez essayer de la cheminée en priorité
des matériels un peu donc vous pouvez
avoir besoin est
et sans être vraiment en rupture qui
aurait eu des conséquences tragiques et
donc pour avoir ces mots des
mathématiques performant s'il nous
fallait intégrer la dimension des
marchands du confinement
c'est dans ce contexte que tu es réunit
l'ensemble des opérateurs des télécoms
européens et séparément des noues confié
dd d'été donnait donc agrégé qui sont
des données qui soit totalement
anonymisée son qui sont des métadonnées
sont déjà complètement con qui sont
vraiment engagés ces deux mots et qui
sont donc on ne peut pas seul connaître
l'origine pour anticiper donc encore une
fois les conséquences du du confinement
dans la lah justesse encore une fois des
résultats
c'était pour nous extrêmement précieux
d'anticipation des pitch est du reste on
a tellement pas besoin d'avoir des
informations personnelles que un
opérateur suffisait par pays mais cette
impression d'être statistiques et
probabiliste qui suffisent largement
donc ici on lui d'accord entre eux pour
nous donner ces données avec un seul
opérateur qui ont décidé casques bleus
perturbés en ce 4e opérateur derrière on
extrapole avec td des modèles
mathématiques et encore une fois c'est
des données qui sont ensuite détruites
mais qui ne servent et qui sont
absolument pas individualiser et qui
sont des domaines des données agrégées
pour affiner le média mathématiques
d'anticipation des pic de la pandémie
mais deuxième élément sur l'action des
données numériques
c'est évidemment quand on commence on
est dans la phase 2 de déconfinement
alors là bon mais les choses sont
extrêmement claires on a des principes
auxquels nous sommes très attachés en
europe et qui ont été dures et sur les
données sur le côté résumer je dirais
dans la réglementation générale sur la
protection des données personnelles qui
lui qui reste évidemment le directeur de
notre notre réflexion sur ces sujets
et qu'ils quittent pas nous arrêter je
dirais la ligne rouge
tous quand tous quand on tousse qu'on
propose en tout cas au niveau de la
commission à deux pas être compatible
avec hergé pt or donc il s'agit
absolument pas de tracking hacking c'est
évidemment utiliser la géolocalisation
mais au contraire d'utiliser sur des
principes extrêmement simple il est
clair donc éventuellement donc des
options de traçage qui serait dans qui
songe évidemment qui permettent lorsque
vous savez tous comme moi que lorsque la
médecin et trois passes d'un patient qui
est qu'il est contaminé qui a le le
commis 19
il lui demande tout de suite ce qu'il a
vu le nom lentement des personnes qui
l'a vu pour pouvoir vérifier que
derrière robin alors qu'ils étaient
jetés pour détecter son environnement
n'a pas été été affectés également donc
ce travail est fait donc en fait des
applications qui permettent de faire de
faire ce genre de choses de façon plus
automatisée et l'utilisation notamment
du coup tout ce qui permet de le faire
qu'est ce que c'est évidemment c'est
tout simplement la possibilité de faire
en sorte que si les mais uniquement sur
la base du volontariat
j'insiste là dessus sinon pas des
moindres contraintes d'un élément
volontariat c'est estime qu'ils veulent
le faire ils peuvent le faire
et qui c'est une démarche citoyenne
on respecte
et pour encore une fois dans la phase de
déconfinement et donc suivre encore
puisqu'on va vivre encore prendre un
certain temps donc de boire pq weiss
normal et bien c'est une application qui
est une application sur lequel
maintenant les pays travaillent il a
fait du travail du travail
tu permets tout simplement lorsqu'elle
est activée que vous l'avez télécharger
la base volontaire
donc d'identifier ce qu'uniquement sur
votre portable est pas et par ailleurs à
ce que vous puissiez avoir accès ou le
cas échéant un médecin si jamais vous
avez été identifié comme étant
potentiellement porteur va au delà de la
maladie
donc ils identifient les les des
personnes que vous avez croisé qu'ils
soient du reste des amis ou des gens rue
rester en contact avec eux en ont plus
de 15 minutes ou 10 minutes
ça dépend évidemment de protocole par
les médecins à une distance sur une
distance qui sera de m et qui fait que
ces personnes sont potentiellement pu
être éventuellement si vous étiez vous
même porteur du virus contaminés ce qui
permet de le renvoyer du noir sssm est
cependant de façon anonyme isère dinan
il serait bon que vous fassiez contrôler
c'est gênant les humains dans un simple
et donc c'est pas du tout du tracking
c'est pas du tout c'est alors jusqu'au
bout on a fait on a donc mis ces
principes dans ce qu'on appelle dans
notre jargon que c'est anglet où le mox
est à dire des lignes directrices en
quelque sorte il l'avait déjà fait avec
la 5g savez très bien fonctionné donc on
l'amitié principe on va pas c'est que je
ne peux résumer avec leur maman le
derrière l'applicatif qui pourrait en
être reçu et on en a discuté avec chacun
des états membres et tous les états
membres ont accepté à l'unanimité
maintenant ces principes directeurs ont
été acceptées par tous et sa bande
jeudi dernier c'est flou c'est tout neuf
et donc est donc mis de façon très
claire ce que l'on pouvait faire en
utilisant comme on devait la vie libre
j'ai président à juste titre la
technologie parce qu'il faut l'utiliser
mais tout en respectant évidemment nos
voiles alors je sais que certains nous
disent ah bah oui mais encore et encore
et en habits du tracking volontaire avec
la géolocalisation en israël mais aussi
en machine mais si on prend ces deux
pays israël est là et la choriste et des
pistes sont en guerre l'accord est
toujours en guerre même si c'est une
grande démocratie
je savais voilà nous on est une autre
démocratie y en a des valeurs a et dans
les airs et donc que les choses ont une
fin
il est important de respecter aussi ce
qu'ils font nos valeurs tout en
utilisant la technologie et si un nombre
important de nos concitoyens de reprise
l'utilisent ça sera un atout important
veiller à ce que cette phase de
déconfinement se passe bien mais je
crois qu en étant très transparent en
expliquant bien ce qu'est ce qu'on fait
en expliquant bien ce qu'on ne fait pas
on espère bien que sur les données
indiquent qu'un bien qu'il peut y avoir
accès qui ne peut pas y avoir accès et
comment ça fonctionne
je pense que finalement j'espère qu'on
pourra convaincre votre grande de nos
concitoyens utilisé dernière question
vous devez poser c'est est sûre apple et
google au caire pour faire parler des
bluetooth avec des systèmes
opérationnels différents les nac et
android et l'autre cas us laisse pour
apple android google
il fallait que les beaux gosses puissent
se parler ce qui n'était pas le cas
auparavant donc apple et google ont
décidé de faire en sorte que leur
bluetooth respectives puissent
communiquer entre eux pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir lancer une application puisse
fonctionner j'ai été moi-même en contact
avec les présidents de google la semaine
dernière j'étais de nouveau un col avec
le président d'apple
cette semaine on vient vérifier ce que
ça fonctionne mais que derrière il n'ya
pas effectivement d'autres éléments nos
services que ce soit uniquement et
d'interopérabilité qui est désert
pourrait fonctionner pour le
fonctionnement mais diamants n'a rien
d'autre et je pense que là on a avec 7
septembre à outils l'ensemble des
directives qui est qui et qui rassure
tout le monde sur exactement ce que l'on
veut faire ce que l'on peut faire et ce
que l'on ne l'accepterons jamais voilà
donc ça c'est pour l'utilisation de la
technologie dans cette période alors
l'honneur des points avant de passer aux
questions à ce que le dernier point
concerne évidemment l'adaptation de
[Musique]
deuxième et reçut la situation de la
crise économique sans précédent que
traverse actuellement
l'immense et tous les secteurs sont
concernés
pratiquement tous les secteurs à part
peut-être quelques-uns de la santé il
est un peu moins cher des télécoms
évidemment les mois mais tous les
secteurs sont très durs très très
impliqué on pense évidemment d'avoir au
tourisme au tourisme transport transport
aérien on pense évidemment à tout ce qui
concerne les petits les commerces de
proximité et des activités de proximité
explique t on pense on pense bien
entendu aux rites elle a des solutions
on pense bien entendu à l'automobile on
pense évidemment l'industrie
aéronautique
on repense au textile on pense pas tous
les citer mais ils sont tous impact
évidemment par le fait qu'ils appuient
l'activité ya plus de demandes
l'offre a été dans certains domaines
casser du reste parce que les lignes de
balai chaîne de valeur les supply chain
ont été ont été stoppés ça je pense
qu'on peut revenir mais tracé assez
mises en place mais revendique seulement
de l'est pas là et évidemment on a eu
l'honneur d'y baisse de 80 à 90%
d'actifs vers moi un rapport dans
certains secteurs dont ceux dont les
premiers exister tout à l'heure et a
besoin absolument urgentissime de
trésorerie d'assistance a très envie
pour toutes ces activités et ça c'est
très très très important et on s'est
beaucoup beaucoup mobilisé là dessus les
états membres ont joué le jeu un très
très très rapidement c'est vrai que ça
prend un peu de temps
la violence a été telle que il faut il a
fallu s'adapter très vite la commission
1 sans tarder et là aussi a réagi
immédiatement en levant de 2,2 de
critères comme du reste les traités y
autoriser à faire le premier ça a été
tout de suite utiliser les états membres
évidemment en cas de force majeure c'est
conforme au traité de ne pas respecter
les critères détenait moins 3% de
déficit évidemment donc là l'article
nérac et s'est appliqué immédiatement on
l'a levé immédiatement de façon à ce que
les états membres puissent immédiatement
d'intervenir en tant que de besoin pour
pour pouvoir faire ses affaires et
notamment pour l'emploi mais pas que et
puis deuxième c'est évidemment tout ce
qui concerne les aides d'état
l'état est donc là aussi on a levé
l'ensemble des contraintes qui
interdisait jusqu'à présent évidemment
les autres à intervenir soit directement
soit indirectement et quand j'ai
directement s'apprête repose désormais
évidemment en prise de participation aux
mondiaux de capital d'entreprises prise
de participation minoritaire voire
majoritaire s'est jamais à me décider
et tout ça a été fait a été mis en place
en une semaine devrait donc reculer par
rapport à la crise de 2008 il ya eu une
activité extrêmement rapide de
l'ensemble des états membres et la
commission
la bce a joué à jouer son rôle aussi on
l'a vu donc d'abord avec la situation
qui a été dit et ce qu'elle était et
puis très rapidement ensuite comme vous
savez une très bonne décision voilà j'ai
progressé techniquement mais aussi d'un
point de vue financier avec la mise en
place des terreaux la mise en place
d'une disponibilité à hauteur de 750
milliards d'euros
donc pour que les états puissent se
refinancer tout de suite et aussi les
états mais aussi des écarts points est
donc
donc il ya eu là aussi une très bonne
réactivité donc de la part de la
présidente de la bce de la part de
l'ensemble des acteurs bon et maintenant
il faut évidemment faire en sorte que ce
que ça suive ça c'est pour l'instant
et j'ai bien conscience que il faut
vraiment veiller à ce que tous et c'est
aussi les mains les garanties qui ont
été mises en place par nancy notamment
de la france portant magnan platitude
des garanties des pays acp joie partout
comme savez je vous soyez à ce que tous
les états membres fassent la même chose
je vais dans un instant j'ai un petit
les préoccupations c'est qu'il faut voir
il faut que l'ensemble des états membres
et les niveaux de dax est d'avoir au
financement de son nez ses actions tout
à fait extraordinaire par rapport aux
héros du temps par rapport au droit
commun demeure de nos fonctionnements
dont il est très important qui est que l
accès identique
chacun a son histoire et chacun son
histoire budgétaire vous me connaissez
j'ai toujours été de ceux qui ont
défendu la nécessité d'avoir de
maintenir un niveau d'endettement
acceptable tout simplement parce que tu
fais c'est que quand si jamais on ne le
fait pas
quand on a précipité de le faire quand
il est attendu arrive on est affaibli
malheureusement comme vous savez cours
des dernières années la france est
passée de 70 % de d'endettement par
rapport à ce que tu es bercy moi même
l'allemagne était à 67,1 me rappelle les
dix ans malheureusement la gestion des
dix dernières années ont fait que france
est passé à 100 % et l'allemagne et
était à 60
voilà donc on aurait très bien pu rester
à 62 ans c'est qu'on a tous eu la même
crise des deux côtés du rhin bon c'est
comme ça on en a déjà parlé connaissez
mon point de vue là dessus je ne tenais
pas changé sauf que là on a une crise
est tout à fait systémique
tout est évidemment tout à fait
exceptionnelle et que c'est précisément
dans ces cas là qui voulut être en bonne
situation voire accès avoir accès aux
financements alors je leur dis si il
n'est pas un pays sur la planète à un
cas les réserves pour financer cette
crise dont les états vont devoir
emprunter tous faut bien qu'on en soit
conscient hauteur mais si jamais il
n'avait pas la capacité d'emprunter
cette housse en faillite
donc on n'appartient pas un état
aujourd'hui que ce soit la haine que
soient les pays bas que ce soit l'italie
soit la france soit les états unis qui
ont tout simplement des réserves du
trésor doit faire face à la crise tous
vont devoir emprunter massivement
donc on n'est plus
dans la discussion il ya les vertueux du
nord les vertus du sud est en chacun si
on bouge pas et of peak
donc chacun va devoir emprunter chacun
doit être égale vis-à-vis en face du
virus burris rate tout le monde mais il
faut évidemment qu'on maintienne
l'intégrité du marché à terre si jamais
lorsqu'une concerne et pas dire maintien
il y en a pour des raisons x ou y qui va
avoir un accès plus facilité que
d'autres ces financements
c'est dans ce sens que j'ai défendue
évidemment avec notamment mon collègue
pâles aux yeux de lille i l'a défendu le
fait qu'il fallait
connaît on va dire un outil particulier
pour financer sept sites cette situation
particulière de notre histoire avec
peut-être des maturités qui soit
différente
alors j'ai ce qu'on a utilisé des mots
comme le corona bon j'aime pas c'est pas
ça s'est il s'agit simplement qu'on
fasse en sorte d'abord de bien
comprendre le montant qui est nécessaire
pour protéger notre tissu industriel
haut niveau au niveau de l'ensemble du
continent européen
veillez à ce que l'épave l'un qui va
dire parce qu'il a réussi plus vite ses
draps ou je ne sais pas par à protéger
un autre nom il faut vraiment qu'on
veille à ce qu'il ya une sorte d'égalité
d'accès encore une fois à ces
financements je le redis tous les
financements qui vont permettre
d'accompagner cette phrase tellement
particulière et donc essayez donc de
faire en sorte que l'on puisse aider
toute l'entreprise et notre suspense en
particulier aux pme
évidemment les plus fragiles mais pas
que il faut que cette espèce d'égalité
de le dire et de comportement vis-à-vis
de cette situation qui est par
définition tout à fait singulière qui
frappe tout le monde de la même façon et
un élément c'est qu'il est important
dans cette période que mon essai on
essaie d'avoir une idée à peu près des
montants nécessaires pour permettre de
passer ce cap qui est comme on l'a dit
tout à l'heure et un câble a été
vraiment un capot va très vite se rendre
compte que de la demande la demande
n'est pas là
et puis aujourd'hui évidemment par
définition on parle d'hélicoptères
monétique et d'en consommer et donc
c'est sûr c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
ça le sujet comme le dit du reste très
très très très opportunément jacques de
larosière vous invite à consulter
il ya deux ou trois jours le sujet c'est
encore une fois d'aider les entreprises
à passer ce cap
et puis derrière de les aider à rebondir
et notamment de les aider à rebondir par
rapport à ce que vous avez indiqué tout
à l'heure
même la présidente monsieur le président
c'est à dire évidemment notamment par
rapport à la politique industrielle qui
avait été arrêté juste avant la crise et
dont je rappelle qu'elle s'articule et
selon trois axes d'abord le benzyl qui
demeure plus que jamais la relation
l'environnement alors avec tout ce que
ça comporte
notre relation à l'environnement la
qualité de l'air à la santé évidemment
qui vont au tour les bains devenir un
des enjeux essentiels le nom le dit
aujourd'hui peut-être puisque puisque
depuis ce que jamais l'importance du
numérique
on le voit bien avec tout ce qu'on a
raté tout à l'heure et puis et puis
aussi ce qu'on avait dit et comme
troisième pilier
c'est une une refonte une revisite des
rapports de force internationaux
notamment à l'aune de cette nouvelle en
jeu voire confrontation dit certains
entre ces trois grands blocs que sont
les états unis l'europe et la chine qui
nous les incite évidemment excuses je
l'avais déjà dit moi même du reste à
revoir la façon dont on va organiser nos
chaînes de production et peut-être
reproduire davantage en europe ces voix
là aussi parce que le digital nous
permet c'est aussi parce que l'économie
circulaire et devenir une importante et
que ça se fait plus localement donc on
avait déjà pas être identifiée tout ça
et vous savez j'ai compris là dessus des
crises
cette ampleur on a tous conscient
maintenant sans savoir très bien on
définir encore le monde le monde le
monde duquel quelques pas qu'elle va
qu'elle va réduire commencé à fléchir
ont commencé à avoir des idées
évidemment est une chose qui est
certaine c'est que je suis mais vraiment
des crises de cette nature mais cette
ampleur sont des accélérateurs
d'accélérateur de tendance
donc j'ai trois tendances que je ne
rappelais visiblement vont être
sensiblement accéléré par par cette
crise et nous nous y préparer et c'est
tout l'objet effectivement
deux hommes je conclus là dessus donc du
mois de mai calibrage financiers dont
j'estime qu'il est nécessaire ou tout
autre secteur économique au sens large
et vous savez que j'ai défini pour la
politique industrielle européenne non
par les chaînes de les secteurs où même
les écosystèmes autour des secteurs
l'écosystème automobile l'industrie
automobile c'est 5 millions d'emplois
l'écosystème autour de l'automobile ça
comporte les distributeurs ça comporte
une et des réparateurs cinq ans par sa
comportent tous ceux qui vivent autour
l'autobus et 15 millions d'emplois donc
donc ces écosystèmes est là il y en a
une quinzaine maintenant en europe
ces écosystèmes qu'il faut préserver il
faut aider évidemment à passer ce cap et
il faut et il faut permettre de rebondir
avec donc des moyens des moyens
appropriés lors si heureux leur
beau-père réussi lors de la foire où
certains se sont émus à côté du reste ça
a été la plus longue réunion je
participais à un dixième de regroupement
entre ministres voilà c'est c'était une
réunion qui a duré presque deux jours
arrêté au bout d'une très longue nuit et
puis interpellé le lendemain c'est aussi
la crise la plus importante depuis
maintenant certains disent allure
décennies voire peut-être même siècle
donc on est passé une nuit à discuter
sans quand même pas complètement quelque
chose d'extraordinaire en tunisie à
partir du sujet vous savez qu'à la
réunion importante de leur groupe
deux décisions qui me semble très
significatives ont été prises
la première c'est d'arrêter un volet de
540 millions à peu près de financements
immédiats donc 200 millions 2,2
milliards dont 900 milliards porté par
la bce ça va être la villa dei va être
mis en oeuvre immédiatement donc c'est
très important parce que c'est très très
opérationnelle le deuxième c'est
évidemment le mécanisme laurence
habilité est ce donc qui était qui n'a
pas été conçu pour ça comme vous savez
conçu pour aider les états j'aurais pu
être en difficulté à la tutelle de crise
financière pour se refinancer sur les
marchés
donc là c'est 240 milliards qui sont
mobilisables donc sans condition les
dégâts avaient des consignes des
conditionnalités évidemment
pour l'heure plutôt d'après ce qu'a dit
leurs groupes tournés vers les
industries autour de la santé et eram le
honduras qui arrêtera conseil européen
et puis l 100 milliards qui ont été
proposées par la commission européenne
comme il savait être vers un faux qu'on
appelait sur qui est un plomb dont un
plan dans un faux kiala qui a vocation à
aider des états qui n'ont pas deux aides
au chômage partiel à pouvoir enfin
bénéficier de l'ensemble des
collaborateurs pour pouvoir maintenir
évidemment les forces vives et lorsque
l'activité redémarre à faire en sorte
qu'elle soit toujours là et qu'on puisse
les airs employés médiatement et puis il
ya une deuxième décision qui a été prise
c'est turbo c'est un fait donc d'avoir
de réfléchir désormais à un quatrième
pilier ses trois premiers danger vient
de parler tu serais donc un fonds alors
est ce que c'est un fonds qui est état
fort peut être parce qu'on te donne
comme l'avait été la caisse est ce que
c'est un faux qui peut être abritée par
la commission tout et tout et tout est
remis sur la table la prison pendant la
haine de didier juste titre il faudra
quasiment un plan marshall c'est le
thème qu'elle utilise et je crois qu'il
était s'est approprié pour précisément
aider à l'industrie européenne de passer
ce cas est de rebondir
voilà donc avec mon collègue carl hozjan
télé ni on a identifié l'ensemble du
paquet alors en gros à 8 500 ou 600
milliards un ca
c'est pas étonnant parce que si vous
voulez je finis là dessus quand vous
voyez ce qu'on fait les états unis ils
ont mis pratiquement 10% leur pnb donc
sur la table pour aider tout de suite
leur entreprise du pays les repères du
pib américain si je vois l'allemagne par
exemple l'allemagne immédiatement après
que été acceptée fait de pouvoir de
pouvoir s'extraire des dires des 3% à
trouver finalement dont la rapidité une
vélocité qui nous surprend parce que
depuis deux mois qu'elle m'a un peu
quand même pour des missions rapidement
malgré cette démocratique vous avez
l'impression des fois on disait qu'il
fallait attendre des mois et des mois
quand l'urgence est là on voit que nos
amis allemands
ça va réagir vite puisqu'au moins d'une
semaine ils ont quand même volé excuser
des fautes excusez du peu
un budget complémentaire de 357
milliards d'euros ce qui est quand même
pas rien s'il dit pour ça on a encore de
leur pib
en complément des 600 milliards et 50
milliards qui avait été mis en garantie
donc pour irriguer immédiatement
l'ensemble des industries allemandes ce
qui est tout à fait important c'est 10 %
du pib là encore que soient les pme se
soit pas intervenir directement auprès
des industriels allemande en prix de
participation avant tout à la fonction
milliards et je pense que le plan du
récit très bons plans inédits du reste
de mes homologues allemands misent sur
des finances s'était mis sur des
musiques limites sont aussi des amis
bien mais je pense qu'il faut faire très
beaux plans renvoi c'est quand même 10 %
du pib
donc on voit que ces montants williams
le pib européen bas 1600 milliards pour
le fonds s'est dit content du pib enfin
donc je pensais à peu ce qu'il faut
avoir en tête peu près en gros ou pour
ce pour l'ensemble du montant qui va
falloir qu'il va falloir mettre sur la
table pour aider à passer ce cap et
rebondir tout en évitant les disparités
pays entre pays c'est très important
pour moi commissaire au marché intérieur
mais aussi en évitant les disparités
entre l'europe et les états unis ou la
chine qui eux ont aussi font pratiquer
ce genre de choses là encore par de
l'endettement je le redis mesdames et
messieurs les saynètes alors je vous le
redis tout cela se fait par endettement
on n'est pas un pays qui peut faire la
morale aux autres si vous voulez on est
tous égaux la voilà donc
donc je pense que ça viendra le moment
de savoir comment on traitera cette
dette est ce que finalement il faut
traiter comme la traiter la dette
héritée du passé est ce que c'est une
bête qui pourra être monétisée avec
c'est un autre sujet chaque jour suffit
sa peine
moi j'ai des idées c'est trop tôt pour
en parler mais en tout cas la priorité
aujourd'hui c'est de tout faire pour
sauver notre tissu industriel et permet
de redémarrer
merci j'ai été très long mais beaucoup
beaucoup d'activités merci beaucoup
monsieur comme ça avec vous et bien
terminée en décembre
si vous n'avez pas le moment de parler
dans des tailles si je peux dire de tel
ou tel point vous avez évoqué
exhaustive juste quelques remarques
avant de donner la parole à sophie
primas qui orchestrera en quelque sorte
les prises de parole les membres de la
commission et comme je le ferai ensuite
pour les membres de la commission des
affaires européennes
je tiens aussi moi aussi a souligné la
réactivité bien le mal en la matière 10%
de ce conflit alors que ce n'était pas
du tout dans sa culture on sait comment
quelle est la structure du bundestag sur
ce point précis
pourrions-nous avoir malgré tout
quelques précisions sur le
fonctionnement du fonds industriel qui
maintenu en place
et puis enfin vous l'avez sous-entendu
il est bien évident que tous les états
vont emprunter ce qui suppose une
maturité des belles qu'ils soient très
longue et la résurgence sans double de
l'inflation qui solutionnera sans doute
pas mal de choses
les peut-être n'avez-vous pas envie
aujourd'hui de parler de ça
au moins de vue
non je peux je je je
je vais lui d'aucune question parce que
je j'ai tout ça en tête j'ai vraiment
tout ça en tête
j'ai été chef d'entreprise je vis
parfaitement ce que l'entreprise j'étais
mise des finances je vis parfaitement ce
que vivent les mises des finances et
j'ai été savaient clairement défenseurs
du maintien de certaines autres d'auxi
budgétaire donc des vies tout ça j'ai
dit simplement nous sommes à un moment
particulier et donc dans cette situation
c'est vrai que l'allemagne a réagi très
vite mais c'est vrai aussi que c'est
tout son tissu industriel est multiforme
qui est atteint donc là il réagir vite
c'est partout puis on est tous pareil en
europe donc et c'est la raison pour
laquelle il faut qu'on ait un accès qui
soit d'accès à ces facilités à ce
financement qui est correct et qu'on le
mette en oeuvre dans deux ans la
rapidité est importante
ensuite il ya beaucoup de possibilités
je veux pas intervenir moi même parce
que là c'est vraiment la vie si c'est ça
c'est la décision des états membres et
la présidente de la commission
ben va défendre notre point de vue bien
entendu je parlais tout à l'heure du
plan marshall qui caractérise l'ampleur
de ce que nous pensons que ça on va voir
ça peut être par exemple dans le budget
dans le but de la commission pour
trouver des moyens des moyens très
importants pour le faire on l'a fait par
exemple au grain sur donc où on séance
est donc le faire on a ce savoir faire
c'est peut être à fond à fond en
particulier
c'est aux états membres à le décider
donc je vais pas me substituer aux états
membres des solutions existent mais ce
que je veux dire moi mon rôle c'est de
donner un l'enveloppent peu près je
crois qu'on a à peu près bien qualifiés
avec mon collègue pas dow jones ligny et
le commissaire aux affaires économiques
sa demande a signé une tribune tous les
deux là dessus parce qu'on est très mais
très lui comme moi ès qualités je dirais
moi parce que j'ai évidemment un marché
intérieur avec l'entreprise en ligne
directe lui parce qu'il à l'économie
donc on a ont exprimé qu'elle était pour
nous une vision du besoin tonifier 1500
1600 milliards il appartient maintenant
aux états membres de se réunir il ya des
solutions différentes qui vont être dès
qu'ils sentent qu'ils sont possibles
j'espère évidemment que ces décisions
sont prises parce que je pense que c'est
ce dont nous avons besoin maintenant ce
qui concerne le surendettement qui va
être qui va être générée par ça
il ya plusieurs ya plusieurs plusieurs
solutions au sommet face à des
situations de surendettement et la 4g
des cités et puis et puis derrière
évidemment
généralement on peut dire que l'addition
des demandes dans l'histoire il a pu
être traitée par des points de parts de
l'inflation massive roux ne souhaite pas
ça tellement pas mon choix par des
augmentations significatives en péritel
que ça servira pas à grand chose donc il
vaut mieux au contraire accompagner la
relance parce que derrière il faut pas
la relance c'est indispensable et
surtout dans des pays comme la france
sont les plus endettés plus c'est que
les taux d'imposition les plus élevés au
monde
attention il faut il faut que derrière
il ya la relance moi je viens de finir a
été vidée au col tous les jours avec
l'écosystème et shine finir une vidéo
call avec la disco mobile
j'ai pas dévoiler enfin si vous voulez
je mesure pleinement de la détresse des
trains ce nombre très important de
distributeurs qui ont des stocks
invraisemblable de voitures sur leur
parking où les loyers c'est gravé sur
l'a10 mais alors combien de temps il va
falloir que je garde ça j'ai pas les
moyens de garder sens au mistook qui va
falloir sans doute qu'il y ait de la
demande qui reviennent comment ils
comment inciter la demande
bon c'est pas en augmentant les impôts
qu'on va essayer l'allemand bayer donc
donc il ya voir qu'on trouvera aussi des
solutions parce qu'on va produire c'est
bien mais enfin il faut derrière les
produits s'écoulent et je peux vous
faire ce type de remarques sur tous les
écosystèmes avec lequel je suis en
interface quotidiennement mais surprise
donc
donc vous ne cessez pas c'est pas la
solution si bien que pour des raisons je
suis du bio rien chacun voit midi à sa
porte
mais voilà moi je vois les sujets de
poissons vraiment macroéconomique est
urgent troisième c'est évidemment
l'annulation des dettes à quelque chose
on n'a pas vu alors pourquoi pas mais
enfin je pense que mon combat et bien je
pense que dans beaucoup d'eau coulera
sous les pots 7e c'est peut-être de
monétiser une partie des dettes
c'est quelque chose serait vous avez
parlé du reste au sénat avait bien
accueilli il ya quelques années ses
collègues de l'été missions de défense
et des affaires étrangères j'avais eu
l'idée d'un fonds européen de défense et
de sécurité qui avaient du reste
progressé depuis puisque c'est à la base
de cette réflexion une infection
citoyenne que né d'un fonds de défense
on histoire avec autour du si je suis le
responsable
je n'ai pas fait ça lorsqu'elle était
venue vous présenter l'idée mais
derrière j'avais déjà imaginé un fond
précisément à très longue maturité qui
permettait de financer
parce qu'on a aujourd'hui des taux
d'intérêt qui sont absents nul ou
négatif et donc sur des missions
d'intérêt d'intérêt général des missions
d'intérêt public grandes transformations
qui donne aux prix vaut d'ailleurs
bénéfices sur sur une longue sur une
longue période 20 ans donc td fond
neutre est très large peuvent se
refinancer sur une très très longue
période et donc y compris du reste de
l'été l'on peut qu'elles ont plus à
demander au bout d'un certain temps la
femme une petite partie d'impôt qui
peuvent être différés ça peut être la
taxe carbone aux frontières
on peut avoir des idées mais donc pour
pour extraire si vous les 7 6 2 6 2 7 6
7 2 7 7 7 d'être complémentaire gd je
viens bien je crois qu'on a bien
qualifier ensemble cette cette période
il va y avoir dans l'histoire de la
lettre cv j'avais souvent l'habitude de
dire que la dette c'est quand vous lisez
une dette c'est une archéologie
mobilisés et viser les strates où il est
l'histoire à travers dans la création de
nos dettes
il y aura une partie alors 15% de 10%
20% on verra qui sera comment le virus a
donc peut-être que cette partie là cette
strate la corona bien us
on peut trouver les moyens et ses
éléments de la sortir on va finir l'art
financier du très très long terme
donc il ya des solutions et c'est ce que
je voulais vous dire qu'ils sont pas des
folies des solutions classiques il
faudra sans doute défaut les solutions
plus innovantes continue encore de la
situation mais chaque jour suffit sa
peine
en tout cas j'ai réfléchis déjà andré
tessier collègues
j'avais beaucoup apprécié ces questions
sur le fond elle défend tant que je suis
bien au fait des mécanismes et c'est
trop tôt pour en parler
beaucoup monsieur le commissaire je me
propose techniquement de donner la
parole à sophie primas qui je me
rappelle d'un orchestré entre guillemets
les prises de paroles des ses
commissaires entre les commissions
d'afféry ce qu a et si vous voulez bien
monsieur le commissaire répondre
globalement à l'ensemble des prises de
parole et ensuite on fera la même chose
avec les collègues de la commission des
affaires européennes
un mac madame la présidente
vous nous entendez
avatar le jeu ne maîtrise pas le leçon
c'est vous monsieur le président bizet
qui avaient ce pouvoir
merci très bien et bien que nous avons
cinq questions de la part des
commissaires de la commission des
affaires économiques le poids la parole
est en premier donné à alain chatillon
puis anne catherine loisier alain qu'il
faut lui donner le sont aussi
oui merci sarko me voilà au lac les
sanitaires a mis en évidence certaines
faiblesses de notre tissu industriel en
particulier ont conscience du quasi
abandon de certaines productions sur le
territoire européen
ce qui met en danger les chaînes de
production totale je pense notamment aux
principaux actifs de l'industrie
pharmaceutique à certaines matières
premières textiles ou à des minéraux
rares nous suivons avec grand intérêt la
mise en oeuvre des projets importants
d'intérêt européen mais piek qui
aboutissent en ce moment au lancement de
champions européens de la batterie
électrique il faut axe
l'airé leur déploiement où en est on
aujourd'hui c'est ma première question
les pierres également sur l'hydrogène
verra t'il un jour son arrivée c'est là
un maillon indispensable de la
transition énergétique
la commission envisage ten un pied est
qu en matière d'intelligence
artificielle
c'est ce qu'a demandé le sénat au delà
des seuls piek quelle politique
envisagée tout pour encourager les
entreprises à relocaliser sur notre sol
européen
quels sont les leviers les plus
efficaces selon vous en termes
d'investissements de fiscalité taxe
carbone aux frontières environnement
réglementaire dans le cadre de la
gestion de la crise économique et de la
préparation de la relance la commission
européenne a annoncé que 240 milliards
d'euros pourraient être mobilisés au
titre du mécanisme européen de stabilité
et une centaine de milliards d'euros au
titre de la banque européenne
d'investissement afin de s'assurer une
efficacité maximum de ces dispositifs
il est particulièrement important que
les critères d'éligibilité à ces aides
soient assouplies kit soient claires
pourriez-vous déjà nous indiquer les
critères qui devraient être retenus
certains d'entre eux certaines
entreprises sont elles plus
particulièrement visés que d'autres mais
seul commissaire vous le savez notre
commission est très engagé sur la
régulation des géants du numérique elle
a fait adopter une proposition de loi
sur ce thème à l'unanimité au sénat
2 le précise avec mon principal
dispositif la neutralité des terminaux
la commission européenne semble très
sains langues sur le sujet mais
malheureusement nous nous inquiétons des
délais inhérents aux procédures
institutionnelles
alors il y a grande urgence la crise
risque de renforcer la position
dominante de certains grands acteurs
pouvez vous nous dire si la régulation
économique du numérique que nous
appelons de nos voeux fait partie de vos
priorités de la précrime sens je vous
remercie monsieur le commissaire et
salue les propos avec marie merci
beaucoup merci alain j'ai oublié de
préciser qu'on doit faire des questions
courtes car là monsieur breton à petit
impérative dans 40 minutes et il ya tous
les commissaires des affaires
européennes
anne catherine loisier et ensuite franck
montaugé
catherine alors on va essayer de franck
montaugé franck faut lui donner la leçon
le son est activée c'est bon comme vous
et ponts et voilà très bien franc
contentant au pouvoir bonjour monsieur
le bonjour à tous à l'occasion de la
présentation par la commission de la
nouvelle stratégie industrielle
vous avez déclaré le commissaire de
qu'au titre de même titre que le critère
de prix les entreprises vont devoir
revoir leur chaîne d'approvisionnement
en prenant en compte dorénavant
l'empreinte carbone la numérisation et
la proximité des lieux oduction par
rapport aux services et aux clients mais
de son côté la france s'est finalement
rallié à déclaration commune de onze
états membres estimant indispensable que
les preuves ne relance prennent en
compte les questions d'environnement et
de et de climat et quant aux patrons des
grandes entreprises ils agissent dans
l'urgence et on peut les comprendre que
soit privilégié le reversement des
entreprises avant les exigences
environnementales
moi je pense que si le débat devait
s'orienter vers croissance ou
décroissance je pense que tout le monde
y perdrait bien poser le problème qui
n'est pas apparu loin s'en faut avec la
pandémie due qu'aux vide c'est répondre
à la question de la nature de la
croissance qui est nécessaire à la vie
au bien-être sur la planète et à la
manière dont cette croissance peut être
représentée est intégré dans les modèles
décisionnel des états et des entreprises
quelle que soit leur taille
donc je vais monsieur le commissaire
européenne je voudrais savoir quelle
initiative concrète la commission
européenne entend prendre pour que les
critères les modèles décisionnel les
entreprises de marchands et de la
finance
intègre les problématiques économiques
sociales environnementales et
culturelles
quels projets ou quelle contribution de
l'union européenne par exemple en
matière d'intégration dans les normes
comptables s'allier férès des enjeux de
décarbonation de biodiversité d'entrée
écologique et cetera
la piste des des objectifs de blom
durable ou d'autres vous par été à cet
égard pertinente
adaptable au futile de transition qui
s'impose dès aujourd'hui aux états
membres et à l'union européenne sur le
numérique le
le sénat a donné une suite la commission
d' enquête dans le cadre de laquelle
nous avons eu le plaisir de
l'auditionner avec avec gérard longuet
comme rapporteur et le sénat a voté une
proposition de loi à l'unanimité qui
traitait de neutralité les terminaux de
l'interopérabilité des plates formes
d'un lutte contre les acquisitions
pedrag prédatrice et de la protection
des internautes à l'égard des interfaces
manipulatoire l'étape d'are patterned
l'allemagne entre autres pays européens
s'est engagé sur des voies tout à fait
comparable avec des critères à la marge
qui sont un petit peu différent je
voudrais savoir ce que c'est que la
crise que nous sommes en train de vivre
vous amène un visage et comme infections
des orientations de la politique
européenne en matière de numérique au
regard en particulier d un enjeu de
souveraineté et de souveraineté
numérique qui est qui apparaissent et
des aspects fondamentaux quant à
l'avenir de l'union européenne notamment
le sénégal aux gammes apple et belang
ont été ok il ya quelques instants mais
je constate que je te donne y sommes en
train de mettre en place des modalités
d'interopérabilité and solar system
merci monsieur merci franck merci franck
on va on va revenir à anne catherine
loisier si vous pouvez lui ouvrir le
sont je pense qu'elle est elle est là
anne catherine et après anne catherine
on aura henri cabanel ces lois la côte
d'or elle n'est pas catherine elles ne
sont alors henri cabanel
elle me dit oui par sms mais bon ça on
va passer à henri cabanel et ensuite
agnès constant et on verra si anne
catherine peut finir henri cabanel merci
voilà la présidence de monsieur le
commissaire
le ministre français de l'économie et
des finances bruno le maire a salué
jeudi dernier un exellent accord actuel
est plein après 50 milliards d'euros
disponibles immédiatement et un fonds de
relance à venir
cette unité roubaix est elle réelle ou
de posture car cours à chaque pays va
abonder ce fonds de relance à venir
alors qu'il existe des divergences une
moyens ne l'avait noté notamment avec
l'allemagne une flexibilité deuxième
question une flexibilité maximale va
désormais permettre de déployer des
fonds structurels de l'union européenne
ont encore utilisés pour pallier les
effets négatifs de la crise
les pêcheurs vont quant à eux pouvoir
bénéficier de mesures spécifiques pour
les soutenir en cas d'arrêt temporaire
de leurs activités ou pour leur stockage
comment cela va s'articuler très concret
n'en est un vin vous l'avez évoqué dans
une question
la mutualisation de la dette donc le
parlement européenne souhaite une forme
de mutualisation de la dette européenne
pour permettre le redressement
économique dans une résolution votée à
une forte majorité 342 voix pour 171 me
contre 128 abstentions les eurodéputés
estiment eux que pour obtenir souvenir
ce manque de vécu obligation de relance
garantis par le budget de l'union
européenne et appelle à la création d'un
fonds de solidarité européen contre le
cours d'un virus d'au moins 5 à 2
milliards d'euros
qu'en pensez vous merci monsieur le
commissaire
merci agnès constant si vous pouvez
découvrir le son agnès oui bonjour à
tous
bonjour monsieur monsieur le commissaire
vous préparez donc actuellement une
boîte à outils fixings plusieurs lignes
directrices sur les applications de
tracking comme vous l'avez plus tôt
expliqué de traçage l'objectif est
d'apporter des garanties solides en
matière de respect de la vie privée pour
nos concitoyens
j'ai bien noté que vous n'envisagiez que
des systèmes sur la base du volontariat
ce dont nous pouvons tous nous féliciter
j'aurais de questions vous avez échangé
avec sound and child dirigeants de
google et le géant apple est aussi en
train de réfléchir à une application
même si je ne doute pas de l'efficacité
dès technologies que pourrait proposer
les gars femme ne peut-on pas privilégié
des entreprises européennes
cela permettrait de pouvoir assurer la
compatibilité et surtout
l'interopérabilité des différentes
applications nationales
deuxièmement et ce de manière plus large
comment envisagez vous la transformation
numérique de la santé publique
cette transformation n'est pas nouvelle
et n'est pas lié qu'à la situation
sanitaire actuelle elle est ancienne
dernièrement dernièrement la feuille de
route de ma santé 2022 a permis le
développement du lsd tu es un bon ou
encore de l'espace numérique de santé
pensez vous qu'à terme il sera
nécessaire de modifier le hergé pour
simplifier l'utilisation des dons des
données numériques et ainsi améliorer la
prise en charge sanitaire des citoyens
je vous remercie
très bien je fais une dernière tentative
très rapide de pour anne catherine
loisier anne catherine elle comme elle
me répond plus en sms je pense qu'elle
n'est pas là donc monsieur le
commissaire on va peut-être vous laisser
répondre à ces questions je reconnais
que c'est bon je suis dégoûté a souvent
eu l'occasion
j'ai encore six autres plus vous écoute
on attendait c'est bon en montrant bien
ça va très bien bon alors donc je vais
essayer de répondre ainsi rapidement
signer sur chaque question vaudrait
beaucoup de temps mais sur la première
la première question oui dans les pièges
sont évidemment un instrument on va
vraiment développé vous avez vous avez
rappelé d'abord le fait que le être que
la crise a fait apparaître mais on
l'avait vu déjà avant la crise du reste
quand on a fait tous notre analyse sur
la stratégie du ciel de l'europe et
quand j'avais déjà commencé à dire que
on rentrait dans une phase n'était pas
globale isation souvenez je vais même
utilisé le terme que deux repas vos
prières mon compte mais qui commence à
utiliser de localisation on est la fois
globale évidemment morning revient un
peu plus local donc je les principes
actifs vous avez raison il était on a vu
parfaitement notamment pour le nice
lille mais pas que il y avait 100 motos
nécessité maintenant les acteurs du
reste de santé eux-mêmes ont décidé de
ne rien patriat sa pomme de production
et je pense qu'on va le voir sur les
tarrare c'est vraiment un terrain il
faut d'abord se trouve c'est vrai
qu'elles sont majoritairement c'est en
chine il faut bien le dire mais j'ai ans
et moi même une mission d expertise nous
avons des tas en europe
donc j'ai lancé une mission d'expertisé
bien en faire le recensement de
l'ensemble des ddd minéraux kedro
disposons est peut-être la la la la la
possibilité de réactiver des mineurs il
faut aider moi tout ça soit soit soit
conforme avec les règles en permettant
là on le sait dans l'extraction
mais nous avons des réserves en europe
et donc il faut voir comment on peut
éventuellement pouvoir les utiliser
je l'étais on en a déjà parlé j'ai
frappé notamment la réalisation rapide
par la force des choses ce qui s'est
passé donc les pieds cui sur l'hydrogène
vous savez qu'on en a on en a commencé à
appeler sur l'annoncé des résultats
n'est pas longtemps sur la tunisie on
gratifie ciel on a on a eu une approche
qui est un peu différente vous souvenez
que sur la toute la réflexion qu'on
avait sur les données et sur
l'intelligence artificielle
j'ai vraiment souhaité à ce qu on est en
amont une réflexion sur le devenir de
rang parce que après tout pas donné pas
d'intelligence artificielle et donc la
nécessité c'est d'avoir une bonne
maîtrise de nos données de savoir ce
qu'on marché est bien comprendre qu
elles nous appartiennent et qu'on puisse
en faire ce qu'on doit en faire un
modèle d'intelligence artificielle due à
utiliser des bonnes données
sachez tous marqués dans les données qui
vont tourner d'y retourner dans les
machines à prenante dans les phases de
machine learning en anglais avant de
pouvoir ensuite les noyer les
algorithmes spécifiques et donc là on a
vraiment je crois des premiers premier
continent à avoir une véritable
stratégie assez offensive en matière de
données j'avais nous est indiqué que les
données industrielles ça allait devenir
le prochain enjeu que l'europe était
très très bien passée c'était avant la
crise les plus jours si on maintient
l'audition du ciel présente plus c'est à
dire s'il fallait une ultima réseau est
en tout cas de cause on a et est donc on
avait des durées de créer un piek comme
vous savez pour avoir des architectures
donc et qui permet de soutenir des des
déclare de localiser donc par secteur
pour pouvoir permettre précisément
d'avoir c'est des stades différents qui
sont agrégés les instants aux autres et
pour pouvoir ensuite permet de
développer des applications
d'intelligence artificielle spécifiques
donc oui mais plutôt à travers donc les
plateformes qui elles mêmes vont
permettre ensuite de développer les
applicatifs
donc là on est vraiment sur la
régulation du numérique
bien sûr quand on est toujours
on est toujours sur la régulation du
numérique c'est puisque vous avez des
eaux c'est une priorité
joris se dire ça prendra aussi une autre
question tu voudrais dire que là des
choses sont sans ambiguïté on le voit au
revoir le rôle que jouent les grandes
les grandes plateformes
glady la première dans le je dirais dans
lol la guerre des données telles que le
talent qu'on la vie avait d'abord les
données personnelles on sait que ça a
été capté d'abord par les parents par
les grandes plateformes américaines ou
chinoises passer des marchés intégrés
très vaste d'accès aux consommateurs les
patrons n'étaient pas du reste
l'innovation technologique majeure vous
allez faut dire les choses comme elles
sont mais en revanche en europe
on était les premiers à développer les
moyens applications à base de données
industrielles pas ce qu'on appelle le la
base industrielle la plus la plus évolué
au monde c'est pour ça que je me bats
voilà comment va maintenir et donc
c'était 7,7 cet aspect des choses est
pour moi très important
la régulation du numérique est fait
partie de nos priorités
le dr on va voir si on peut le faire
avant la fin de l'année où tout utah
prennent enfin je ne ferai pas trop
vision décalée de la jada on va essayer
de décaler le minimum on fait tout le
temps et je veux vraiment éviter qu'on
décale avec la crise qu'on avait pour
décaler notre propre agenda en
particulier en numérique
donc je vous rejoins jour rassure sur ce
sur ce point alors ceci étant dit et
d'intéressant dans l'ain le dialogue que
que j'entretiens avec son décompte plate
forme en ce moment pour les demander
j'avais presque dire les inciter à boire
ou le citoyen elles répondent présents
et sont là et c'est en ag mais je n'ai
jamais eu un dialogue signature avec un
paravent c'était j'ai quand même dit à
plusieurs reprises cette plateforme à
s'adapter à nous reprenons pas nouveau
plein de deux plateformes
je dédie à traîne au moins deux reprises
bon en même temps c'est clair mais soit
avec le présente facebook avec le
président de google faveur d'apple
que ce soit avec toutes les grandes
écoles fournisseur de plateformes j'ai
un dialogue personnel et je peux vous
dire que voilà je n'en dis là ça va
passer l'effectif 11 heures il faut
bouffer les choses ça
réagit alors ça veut pas dire que papa
la réglementer mais ce que je veux dire
c'est pendant cette période
une période qui tracte amant
particulière gg j'ai vu que ce qui nous
avait demandé beaucoup beaucoup
d'énergie et les peu de succès pour
mieux connaître auparavant
ça commence à évoluer comme je leur ai
dit ça ne marcheront pas dire quoi par
réguler on va réguler donc tiendra
compte évidemment dans la régulation
voir comment vos comportements vont
changer pour que vous adaptiez
évidemment à l'ensemble de nos demandes
sur la neutralité sur le fait que les
effects ne soient contrôlés qui n'est
pas la situation et ne cesse de prendre
des produits crochet mais pas de grands
risques
c'est où tous les éléments sont l'un des
convois quelque chose qui ne va pas je
constate que ça commence à réagir
bon bah on va voir ensuite jusqu où on
va on va réguler et ils savent très bien
que si jamais que moi j'ai toujours
maintenu comme objectif que d être
condamnés à trouver décalé parce que
parce que je veux vraiment quelque chose
comme ça au caire en tout cas je
commence à sentir une inflexion si on
prenait 0 naïveté je les connais tous
très bien très très bien j'ai 7e et
depuis longtemps
plus exactement qui sont et je reconnais
qu'ils jouent leur jeu le jour ce moment
ce que je leur demande il le faut je
suis obligé de me dire c'est une bonne
chose mais aussi de ceci étant dit voilà
c'est un dialogue permanent et derrière
comme je le disais du reste le reste
c'était un homme à zuckerberg dans le
monde de l'information dans le monde et
donner tout ce qui n'est pas interdit
n'est pas forcément autorisé regarde les
chiffres on doit être fier attention
permanence où on n'est pas ce qu'on fait
elles sont à pac man ça on régule et on
réglera croyez-moi si jamais on se rend
compte que ça ne va pas et on a un
certain nombre de listes dont on estime
qu'elles ne vont pas encore en ce qui
concerne
l'environnement bon là encore alors
est-ce qu'il faut intégrer dans les ans
comptable énorme il ferait tout ce qui
est développement durable etc
il faut quand même être très honnête et
je veux le dire il ya une très grande
évolution de la part des entreprises
en ce qui concerne le rapport au
développement dur maintenant du reste la
plupart des grandes entreprises et
kangoo publiera un rapport annuel c'est
un rapport développement durable
il ya eu vraiment une prise de
conscience au cours des dix dernières
années que ce soit vraiment en témoigner
la plupart du reste des critères de
développement durable sont primés tenant
compte en tout cas c'est dans le monde
avant la crise à nantes après la crise
mais dans le cas des rémunérations des
managers les critères de développement
durable sont extrêmement importants il
ya une dimension nouvelle évidemment qui
étaient déjà là sur l'apa de carbone est
ce qu'il faut est ce qu'il faut ensuite
les mettre dans les normes et frs on va
voir on en est pas on en est pas encore
là mais on ne s'interdit on ne
s'interdit rien en tout état de cause ce
qui est ce qui est certain c'est que je
dois vous dire que d'abord aujourd'hui
avec cette crise
je voulais porter témoignage du fait qu'
il ya un mot qui me revient maintenant
et que que ce que je vis tous les jours
c'était peut-être pas aussi prégnant
notamment dans notre pays mais pas que
c'est la solidarité
on avait vraiment le sentiment que le
piano dans une époque où
l'individualisme 2 et roire tous les
niveaux et pas qu'en france et moi voilà
je veux porter ce témoignage
j'ai accepté cette mission avec beaucoup
d'eux beaucoup d'enthousiasmé je mesure
parfaitement l'honneur qui m'est fait et
la responsabilité aussi
est-ce que je me fais vraiment avec la
solidarité chevillée au corps mais je le
vois je bois solide a été jouée
aujourd'hui le bon évidemment avec tous
nos concitoyens
les premiers d'entre eux c'est les
personnels de santé qui sont là et tous
ceux qui font fonctionner encore notre
notre pays dans quasiment l'arrêt mais
chaney on les voit tous les jours on les
applaudit à 8 à huit heures du soir tous
les jours c'est légitime mais la
solidarité je le dis aussi parce que je
le vis entre les pays européens
on n'est pas que enfin de va il ya de la
solidarité notamment tout ce qu'on a
fait les outils qu'on a mis en place je
croyais moi je je je le voyais tous les
jours j'ai les évolutions de pique
j'aime là il falloir qu'on essaie de
voir ça peut donner un peu de matériel
ici à l'espagne va manquer de ça et la
solidarité elle fonctionne elle peut
être pas visibles mais elle fonctionne
mais aussi la solidarité au niveau des
continents alors certains on voulait
peut-être lui a retiré le très utilisé
mais la solidarité entre la chine et non
l'europe et la chine la solidarité entre
autres entrées avec avec je pense qu'on
ne sortira je pense que pendant six
heures à me sortir à cette situation au
niveau planétaire qu'en étant solidaires
les uns les autres et pas opposé
je dis ça parce que c'est un élément
important à quelques questions ensuite
un sur elle
voilà la mutualisation de la dette etc
les flexibilités des obligations je je
je le dis on en est pas encore là
moi moi je suis chacun chacun la dette
dans son rôle
mon rôle à moi c'est d'alerter de dire
exactement ce ce que je vois pour le
besoin du tissu économique puis sociale
évidemment on pourra passer cette crise
et de le chiffrer
je les fais je la fine j'ai une
réflexion qui est maintenant acquis
assez nourri articuler la présidente
reprise bien entendu sur flambeau il est
le porte pleinement vous savez qu'avec
ce plan marshall donc je prends tout à
l'heure et maintenant il faut trouver
évidemment est évidemment le meilleur
moyen de le financer et surtout j'allais
dire de façon à ce que l'ensemble des
pays européens partagent cet acte
urgence parce que effectivement ce qui
est important c'est l'urgence de la mise
en oeuvre de ces de ce mode de
financement qui prennent l'aspect
n'affronte pas un aspect d'une
utilisation
je n'aime pas le mot de mutualisation
des dettes parce que si on dit
mutualisation des dettes
pression que l'on veut m'utiliser de
passes aidant j'ai bien dit il faut
caractériser la période pour ce qu'elle
est oubliant passé le pastis traitera
comme il ya ceux prêtés et de rêver les
outils là on est dans une période
particulière il faut le traiter avec des
outils particuliers cette période c'est
pas la mutualisation des dettes tout
simplement c'est de se dire que voilà on
est on est on est ensemble et on essaie
d'avoir un accès qui est un accès
équitable et égalitaire entre tous
par rapport à un instrument de
financement ne s'agit pas dire y'en a
qui vont payer puisque l'eau est encore
une fois chacun y aura accès pour
atteint les pourcentages ce sombre de ce
2 de son pib
donc voilà c'est pas des obligations de
relance et cetera
je pense qu'il faut les mots les mots
sont importants aussi bien économique en
politique à vous tuer la prendre et donc
je pense que là il faut simplement avoir
il ya les instruments sont les connaît
les outils on les connaît il faut juste
qu'on s'a qu'on soit d'accord maintenant
au niveau des 27 sur le montant qui sera
nécessaire et qu'on en discute et moi
j'étais très forts arguments pour
démontrer c'est à dire le bien fondé de
la demande que je vois moi qui vient de
la base
j'ai parlé tout à l'heure la commission
peut l'assurer évidemment dans le cadre
de ces discussions sur le ff c'est une
option qui est sur la table crédible et
légitime
il y en ad'autres aux états membres de
décider sur la dernière question je
voudrais bien repréciser vous avez
référence de référence un homme constant
la masia triste constat vaut à mes
discussions avec monsieur thunder pitch
haïti cook
il s'agit et non entre cas sur un point
les applications de qu'on parle
d'applications de suivi et de suivi a
pas de femme pas de tracking donc
l'application suivi volontaires aux
applications qui seront développés en
europe et on a toutes les compétences
consorts et croyez moi je les ai tous
vus à la rihanna il y en a un en france
allemagne il rien contre avec la
fondation institut tout le monde il ya
un an ce seront des applications qui
seront rendues confort n'a fait on
accepte boxe elle est faite maintenant
elle a été acceptée
faire là encore c'était quand même c'est
une grande réussite parce que tous les
pays européens ont accepté jeudi dernier
donc on n'est pas dans la réflexion de
la philosophie c'est derrière nous les
guidelines les directrices par dont
elles sont là elles ont été arrêtées
ça y est elles sont claires on sait
exactement ce qu'on veut tous les 27
unanime
je le dis parce que c'est quand même pas
rien sur des questions aussi sensibles
que ceux là donc c'est ce qu'on veut pas
ça existe cette boîte à outils sedin
directrice et tout box elle est
accessible sur internet où il a consulté
et bien entendu ils étaient ensemble des
entreprises européennes qui travaille
pour développer des applications ont
évidemment les respecter si on a été
rapide européenne qu'il faut abaisser
ils ont fabriqué ces plateformes ce
qu'on demande en revanche apple et
google
simplement que quand vous êtes si
beaucoup si vous êtes dans la rue et que
vous croisez quelqu'un je dis n'importe
quoi mais transports en commun à m
pendant deux minutes avec quelqu'un et
puis il se trouve que cette malheureuse
personnes d'avoir le les porteuses du
virus et bien on vous dira que vous avez
croisé vous posera pas qui sait vous
dira pas quand mais c'est une personne
mais pourquoi que son système s'il avait
réactivé qu'elle était volontaire d'une
plate forme et qu'elle était sur android
et si vous étiez sur un os il faut au
moins vous de bluetooth puisieux
puissent se parler c'est tout ce qu'on
leur demande n'augmente pas sur les
plates formes pour nous les choses
soient bien claires et c'est pour ça que
ça me permet de le de le redire et pour
les données santé vient précisément dans
les écosystèmes et lorsque j'avais
jamais présenté la stratégie des données
la socialiste est donné et tout a volé
sur les données de santé dont les coûts
d'habitude la rapidité je vois cool on
fait les gros yeux parce que je suis
trop de réponses
tous ces sujets ont été traités dans le
cadre de la stratégie sur les données
sur les données sur le descente et je
vous suis évidemment un sujet un peu un
pas important mais on peut le traiter je
pense tout en respectant la rgpp
je sais que votre temps est compté il
nous reste malgré tout cinq collègues
commission différents en veine de leur
demander de façon très concise de
s'exprimer si vous ne pouviez pas leur
donner la réponse
oran
mais que vos services à ce moment on va
leur demander de faire des cours la
première c'est pascal allizard est très
court pascal parce qu'elle a mise à
pleurer
allumez votre micro pascal allizard
alors jours par banquiers je vais
demander à dj mari didier marie merci
président argumentant des volets très
bien peut enfin écoutez c'est un peu
frustrant de ne pouvoir vous posez
toutes les questions envisagée mais je
vais essayer d'être au plus brefs
à la suite de la crise financière qui a
mis à mal nos économies la chine entre
2010 et 2019 a investi semble-t-il près
de 145 milliards d'euros dans des
domaines stratégiques comme les
infrastructures télécommunications
transport énergie et autres comment
éviter que la crise économique et
financière qui va résulter de la crise
sanitaire ne se traduise par une
nouvelle offensive de ce pays et
éventuellement de quelques autres qui
pourraient être tentés de prendre le
contrôle de nouvelles entreprises
d'infrastructures stratégiques
première question la seconde vous avez
dit sue comme serre que nous sommes
allés trop loin son chemin de la
mondialisation que sur simple réponse
compliqué comment relocaliser la
commission européenne a considéré que la
chine était à la fois un partenaire et
un rival systémique
comment sur le plan international peser
entre ce grand pays que les etats unis
pour que l'europe fasse entendre sa voix
enfin dj fini d'apprendre
[Musique]
olivier noms qui me réjouit mais enfin
drain gâteau là oui merci monsieur le
commissaire pour la précision de vos
propos merci monsieur le président vous
avez abordé la question de la phase de
post globalisation et ma question
confort concerne la la politique de
concurrence européenne
est-ce que vous pensez que on peut avoir
une politique de concurrence européenne
qui risque qui reste principalement basé
sur le prix final pour le consommateur
et comment peut-on mieux lutter contre
le dumping social et le dumping
environnemental
et comment voyez vous la politique de
concurrence européenne de demain je vous
remercie
merci est ce que parce qu'elle est
bienvenue comme ce gros jeux nord puis
au début tout le weed messieurs
prudemment vous m'entendez oui oui
monsieur commissaire bonjour ma cause ma
question concerne l'agriculture qui est
apparue après la santé comme le deuxième
front et son sel dans la gestion de la
crise du collier de 19
la question de l'indépendance
alimentaire revient souvent dans les
débats
celle ci pourrait être fragilisé si
certaines de nos filières ne se
remettait pas de la crise sanitaire
la commission européenne a pris un
certain nombre de mesures de soutien au
secteur agricole
mais la proche du déconfinement en
europe va entraîner un déstockage
important de produits une perspective
qui pourrait fragiliser les cours
comment voyez-vous ce risque sur le
marché européen et quelle réponse
apporter à la nécessité de réguler
l'écoulement des produits
merci jean marc lucas thwala n'est plus
en ligne
je mettais ma fortune celle de monsieur
rappaz comment on arrive on rejoint
monsieur pascal allizard monsieur
copains sénateurs de réorienter les
objectifs de réseaux en europe
vers la plus sûre le sanitaire fait pas
à joindre un dernier colère parce
qu'elle a mises à jour je vous invite à
répondre à ses collègues mais même si
merci pour vos questions le jeu
commencer par le sénateur didier marie
donc là vous avez parfaitement raison de
parler de la chine
comme je le disais tout à l'heure cette
crise historique va certainement joué un
rôle d'accélérateur dans toutes les
tendances que l'on voyait y compris du
reste dans le dernier volet que j'avais
indiqué tout à l'heure c'est à dire une
tension des rapports entre la chine et
les états unis
on le voit tous les jours et je vous
confirme au tchad d'abidjan reste à
choisir vous l'avez déjà fait du reste
une excellente interview du ministre des
affaires étrangères cet après midi dans
un journal du soir
je partage à 100 % c'est son analyse et
je pense que ça va devenir un enjeu
absolument majeur des moyens d qui
viennent y compris sans doute un envieux
qui va s'inviter qui risquent de
s'inviter dans le cadre des élections
américaines
mais nous sortons du cadre de cette
audition mais je voulais vous dire
l'état d'esprit dans lequel je suis pour
répondre à votre question est donc je
partage à 100 % la pertinence ça nous
invite évidemment à nous poser la
question nous européens et et j'en parle
beaucoup avec mon collègue joseph
bourrel qui je partage beaucoup de
choses pour s'entraîner avec lui savait
que c'est le haut représentant
mais je suis content de la défense
représentant donc on travaille beaucoup
ensemble et donc il ya deux aspects
trois aspects le premier c'est
évidemment il faut maintenir lorsqu'on
appelle dans le jargon on dit
j'arrive pas à trouver la bonne
traduction française c'est le level
playing field goal pique nique ça veut
dire être à peu près équitable avoir d
avoir avoir et avoir des zones de
système équitable ou avant une bonne
concurrence entre les états et entre
nous j'en ai parlé tout à l'heure
ok il n'est pas trop de disparités pour
qu'on maintienne bien ces marchés
intérieurs tels qu'ils étaient
auparavant avant la crise mais aussi
entre les continents
quand on voit effectivement est ce que
la question que vous posez un peu là on
peut la retourner aussi avec les
américains quand on voit effectivement
que aux états unis énormément d'argent
dans je vous ai rappelé que 2200
milliards de dollars ont été votés en
l'espace de quelques jours ou par le
congrès américain pour des airs pour
venir en soutien de parties très
important des entreprises américaines
on a vu par on a vu par exemple pour les
quatre entreprises aériennes dans spy
américain s'est pas de l'ovale de 25
milliards de dollars qui sont venus en
soutien immédiat de la part du secteur
it américaine donc donc là là encore il
faut il faut il faut les chinois font
pareil donc il faut c'est pour cela que
j'insiste pour le fait que nous ayons
nous aussi un montant qu'il soit à peu
près comparable tout simplement faire en
sorte qu' il n'y ait pas de disparité de
concurrence aussi entre ceux qui vont
bénéficier dans la crise
le montant très substantiel sous
prétexte légitime fumée passant cause de
les accompagner et ceux qui ne
bénéficieraient pas parce que lorsqu
elle a un frère est évidemment un
affaiblissement majeur de notre
industrie qui pourrait devenir l'objet
de créateurs et comme vous l'indiquez se
marient dans votre question en filigrane
donc c'est quelque chose auquel je suis
extrêmement attentifs et c'est la raison
pour laquelle je me bats pour qu'on
puisse redonner évidemment même de façon
temporaire
on vous me connaissez depuis longtemps
au sénat je crois que je n'ai jamais été
suspect d'être d'être des traîtres
maintenant ardent défenseur des
nationalisations
eh bien voyez-vous là je vous dis que
dans cette période là
si des entreprises ont besoin
d'interventions des temps il faudra
faire évidemment par rapport à ces deux
périodes façon temporaire en ayant de
bonne gouvernance
mais c'est indispensable
il faut maintenir ce niveau d'équité en
sortir venu évidemment avec à bonn avec
la bonne gouvernance qui va bien c'est
dans les instruments
il peut être mise en oeuvre évidemment
si on sent que des entreprises
stratégiques sont en fragilité par
rapport à des actes qu'il ya tout un tas
d'autres instruments dans lesquels on
travaille avec mon collègue phil hogan
pour veiller interdire les prises de
participation ou l'épée de l'entreprise
même s'ils ont déjà directement ou
indirectement ou directement à une des
capitales entre les états et on pense
notamment aux entreprises chinoises
donc on est comme un cantique à ça on a
des instruments les états membres
maintenant on les instruments rappelle
que la france j'ai décidé d'un fonds
d'un milliard d'euros pour intervenir
directement ou indirectement à mendès
france l allemagne c'est 100 milliards
d'euros la haie et et puis comme je le
dis on a on a on a tous les instruments
qu'il utilise qui vont bien maintenant
mais on y est extrêmement dense mais
j'insiste encore une fois sur la double
double dimension qui souvent n'apparaît
pas encore dans le débat il faut il
s'agit pas de jeter l'argent par les
fenêtres cet âge on l'a pas l'argent
qu'on va emprunter donc qui par
définition engage en garde notre avenir
et celui de nos enfants nous l'oublions
jamais c'est donc ce sera pour tous et
pour toute la planète
c'est un emprunt nouveau nous ciel
emprunté par parenthèse planète
on apprend que cela vient aux enfants
avec le climat on emprunte pour notre
bien-être sans prédécent payer nos
dettes et on espère qu les déficits on
enfin désormais pour régler la crise
déco vite enfin bon une fois qu'on a dit
ça et il faut il faut qu il faut qu'on
soit conscient qu' il faut mettre
évidemment nos tissus industriels
notre notre tissu social et que donc il
faut faire des choses à peu près
comparable a donc envoyé en eau comme
moyen pablo et puis le dernier point
c'est évidemment il s'agit pas de faire
en sorte que l'europe devienne le
terrain de jeu entre la chine et les
états unis
voilà ça c'est hors de question donc il
faut évidemment que nous ayons lequel
qu'on maintienne la compétitivité de
notre économie
que nous ayons enfin quelque chose que
j'appelle de mes voeux depuis longtemps
et vous savez là encore sénat pour
m'avoir sujet c'est à dire une plus
grande autonomie en matière de défense
et de sécurité
c'est un sujet que porte en moi et que
je pense qu'il est indispensable de
porter j'espère que ça sera un bal
accéléré on regarde cette crise aussi
mais c'est très important d'avoir la
maîtrise de notre industrie stratégie de
défense
c'est important d'avoir une meilleure
coopération entre nous c'est important
d'avoir un fonds de défense et de la
défense tels que celui dont j'ai la
charge qu'ils soient suffisamment doté
pour pouvoir mieux préparer l'avenir ne
pas dépendre il des uns et des autres
donc je me bats je me bats là dessus
parce que ça fait partie évidemment des
arguments et j'espère ils mangent
entendent bien continuer à le dire les
montants pas le dire que cette période
réveil ce qu'ils étaient un peu
réticents qui pensaient peut-être de
façon un peu dans leur histoire je ne
porte pas de jugement je veux pas dire
naïveté mais par leur histoire
chaque état membre à chaque pays aura sa
propre histoire sa propre relation
inappropriée de défense en assurant
vouloir parler mais que là on se rend
bien compte que de plus en plus je
dirais que bien sûr qu'on aura des
alliances bien sûr qu'on aura des
partenaires on est de plus en plus seul
lorsqu'il concerne je dirais notre
autonomie notre indépendance
donc il faut en tirer les conséquences
j'espère que là aussi ça aura un effet
d'accélération
à travers cet écrit le sénateur hainaut
sur le post globalisation et je vais je
vais et sur la politique de concurrence
je vous invite oui j'avais pas tendu y'a
pas que ça ce marché que des amis mais
enfin je n'ai pas attendu pour dire haut
et fort ce que j'ai présenté la
politique industrielle de l'union auquel
on dire que jusqu'à présent politique de
concurrence et est dû un peu trop pour
dire que c'était le seul but était de
permettre de faire en sorte que le
consommateur ils étaient toujours les
plus bas et que désormais moi je
présentais une politique et industriel
il y avait fait en sorte que l'appareil
politique de concurrence était celle qui
permettrait aux entreprises de revenir
au centre du jeu
c'était avant la crise ça l'est encore
plus vrai aujourd'hui
vous connaissez ma philosophie vous
savez je suis vous savez pourquoi il
veut le match j'ai pas changé mais là
aussi ça la crise ap au moins un effet
d'accélérateur
madame la sénatrice jouve sur
l'agriculture c'est un sujet absolument
essentiel et j'en ai pas assez parlé
pendant que l'on domaine direct parce
que la commissaire à l'agriculture
et je peux vous dire qu'en matière
agroalimentaire ça suive est absolument
essentiel vous avez répond vous avez
raison c'est un sujet qu'on regardera
aussi comment l'aider je pense en
particulier un sujet particulier dont on
parle pas beaucoup mais j'en ai beaucoup
parce que je suis donc notamment par te
fait proprement suite industries
agroalimentaires et on n'en parlait pas
plus tard qu hier avec 'the avec tout
l'écosystème agroalimentaire on a un
problème aujourd'hui avec le lait par
quand on sait pas il ya évidemment
puisque il va au lycée article 222 nos
scènes et et on sait pas le comment de
stocker il faut le stock est pas encore
là il faut il donc ont donc je suis
parfaitement conscient du sujet on va
traiter il faut traiter comme il se doit
avec l'état d'urgence qui s'imposent
je suis bien bien sensibilisés à ces
questions sur la dernière question sur
aurizon l'europe vers le sanitaire je
suis pas sûr je pense qu'on va avoir des
fonds payés par exemple dans le msc tel
qu'il a été requalifié les 240 milliards
d'euros qui sont maintenant mis à
disposition du ms uniquement pour les
industries de santé du monde sanitaire
je pense qu'on a là s'était arrêtée par
leur groupe
je pense qu'on a des moyens des moyens
très significatifs sont donnés en
complément et de façon tout à fait dix
victimes
donc je pense c'est pas la peine de
revoir aujourd'hui les horizons des tas
de couverture très très importante et je
pense qu'il faut les mains il faut
maintenir les programmes mais on a
finalement des programmes
complémentaires pour pouvoir utiliser
qui ne passait pas auparavant
donc moi je pense qu'il faut il faut il
maintenir au maximum les les problèmes
d'horizon europe et voir si ce n'est pas
d'autres programmes de tous les
financements que notre montée qui
pourront aller s'orienter plutôt vers le
sanitaire qui donc vous montrer notre
but c'est évidemment un enjeu qui allait
devenir de plus en plus important tout à
fait légitimement pour les décennies qui
viennent
parce que le commissaire un grand merci
et je sais que votre temps est un parti
nous aurions voulu vous gardé beaucoup
plus longtemps encore lorsque j'essayais
d'autre que les corps et souhaitez vous
poser des questions
on va aller collecter on va vous les
adresser entre guillemets par voie et
emails par voie électronique et
j'insiste je te bien puisque vous avez
apprécié tout et lorsque tu es la
question madame jours à propos des
problématiques agricoles comme vous avez
dans votre périmètre
les industries alimentaires très
sincèrement le sénat depuis sept ans
veut véritablement faire en sorte de
relancer en place une agriculture par
rapport à la politique de l'autorité de
la concurrence avoir regardé les
consommateurs pendant pratiquement un
demi-siècle je suis bien on a oublié de
regarder le producteur et la maintenance
et le producteur donc l'activation de
l'article 222 sophie primas le rang des
commissions des affaires économiques et
moi même au niveau des conditions
d'achat rentable nous avons une
progression de résolution qui est en
passe et je dirais d'être adopté lorsque
nous serons dans un fonctionnement
normal mais nous allons vous a précédé
maintenant cela pour que vous puissiez
faire pression auprès de m un monologue
avec les cultures le présenter le moment
c'est déjà lui aussi bien au courant de
cette affaire
merci à nouveau livré 2 mai désolé si je
n'ai pas pu répondre à l'ensemble de vos
questions mais le sujet est extrêmement
vaste
enfin voila vous voyez que je suis aux
côtés du sénat et chacun là nous sommes
nous nous battons et ça aussi je connais
ce te ment de là où suis je tenais à
vous remercier
je sais aussi que vous avez des rôles
qui sont difficiles sur le terrain
auprès de près de vos mères qui joue un
rôle absolument essentiel dans cette
période qui vont jouer un rôle encore
plus important dans l'appel de
déconfinement puisqu'il pour avoir la
charge est fier que les choses se
passent correctement et donc merci pour
le rôle que vous jouez pour pour notre
pays et moi j'essaye de faux ennemis à
pour nous tous et pour vous en
particulier de là je suis désormais je
serai toujours à disposition ainsi
monsieur le commissaire
merci beaucoup merci infiniment à
bientôt
c'est à l'audition du commissaire
européen au marché intérieur thierry
breton il a présenté aux sénateurs
le plan d'urgence de la zone euro qui
s'élève à 500 milliards d'euros
mais des questions subsistent encore sur
l'orientation de ses investissements on
sait qu emmanuel macron le président
français privilégie la piste des
secteurs stratégiques européens à
préserver d'éventuels absorption de
groupes chinois ou américains les
sénateurs dans cette audition ont
beaucoup insisté sur l'importance de
l'égalité d'accès des pays européens à
ces aides financières que ce soit
l'allemagne ou la grèce voilà c'est la
fin de cette émission merci de l'avoir
suivi vous pouvez revoir toutes les
auditions du sénat sur cette crise du
corps des virus sur notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
je vous souhaite une très belle journée
sur public sénat
[Musique]